jocko what motivates you
i heard you mentioned the man in the
cave can you go deeper on this
what motivates me
well i've talked about this before and
it's kind of what we were talking about
a couple minutes ago as well
and that is first of all with the man in
the cave
and this idea and this thought of
the enemy and and
that was a thought that used to drive me
and
kind of haunt me and make me get up
early and work hard to push myself
because i knew that
somewhere out there
there was an enemy a real enemy a real
man
a person a human
that was waiting for me and that was
preparing
for me and
therefore i needed
to prepare for him i needed to be ready
i needed to be the things i always talk
about i needed to be stronger and faster
and smarter and better
so that when we did meet on the
battlefield
i would be ready for that
rendezvous for that meeting that fate
that battle
and that thought that thought of the
enemy
yes it absolutely fueled me
and when i was a leader in the seal
teams in charge of
men it was even more profound
because i was thinking about that
rendezvous
for everybody that i led everyone i was
in charge of everyone that i trained
and i felt that burden the burden of
responsibility
to prepare those men and protect those
those men those those frog men
those warriors
my brothers
and it it was my burden
to train those guys and prepare them
and that burden it may have made me a
little bit
crazy a little bit paranoid a little bit
over the top
but i didn't really know
any
any other way
and so now
i am no longer
a combat leader
i no longer prepare men for war
so the drive
and the motivation
is from a different place
it's from a solemn place
the drive now and the motivation now is
not really from the enemy anymore
now it's from my friends my brothers
it's from those
seals that i knew
and that i
cared about more than anything
and that they sacrificed
everything
for us and for me and those guys
they gave their lives for us
and now i cannot
help but think and remember
that every breath that we take
is a it's a
gift it's a sacred gift
from those men
every day we have every sunrise
every thought and every smile and every
laugh
it's a gift
and i will treasure
that gift that gift of life
and i will not let it go to waste not
one
second of it
and i'll cherish every moment of it
and i will live it
i will live it
in their memory
and in their honor